[Music]
so about five years ago i was doing a
play at williamstown theater festival
which i think i reference on almost
every episode and um it was with one of
the greatest opera singers in the world
uh renee fleming and it happened to be
her first play
we went out
celebrating one night christian
as you know my brother uh bought her her
first shot shot of alcohol yeah first
ever
i don't know why we're that surprised
she's this extremely
classy yeah but she's she's not 14
certainly not an old woman but she is um
older than you yes she's older than me
and and for her to not have ever had a
shot and she and i should say she's fun
she's not like some stuffy you know
you think of an opera singer she think
of some you know valkyrie so fun and i
think me providing her with her first
shot
made her a bit more human and debauched
and
uh i think
that classy
uh world-renowned respected aura that
she has
is maybe just a little dimmer now so
you're welcome world
and you're welcome renee she was very
appreciative it was a fun night yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
from wondering this is life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and as always i'm here with my brother
christian
long hi justin long hi christian long
weird i don't think it becomes a shock
to anyone that we're both nerds but
there are degrees of nerdiness i've
noticed over the years since my early
days as a nerd i've been very acutely
aware of nerdy behavior and i often play
nerds
when we both encounter a nerd i think
the same is true of you we notice
behavior we notice nerdy behavior um so
that night we got a little inebriated
with the great renee fleming
we were in a group of about seven or
eight people and in that group included
in that group was the actress anna
klumsky who is our guest today yep we
had so much fun that night and that's i
think when you met anna right it is yes
we've been working together for a couple
weeks what were your impressions of her
then and now
this may sound insulting but i genuinely
don't mean it to be my impression is
that she is a huge
nerd
it's hard to say that in not something
it is but but i don't mean it yeah
no i know we it's actually kind of a
cool thing and i don't think i would say
that if not for the fact that she
acknowledged
to be the case you can't get around it
it's just such a truth about her it's
like michael jordan is a you can't deny
you might not be your favorite
basketball player but you can't deny
that he's good at basketball yeah
exactly you know exactly it's that
obvious so and we witnessed what did she
do when she first came in i saw this
whole thing
play out so she came into the studio and
she was preparing her self a coffee she
went into the fridge and and got a
little thing of almond milk out and
sniffed it
poured a little bit into her coffee
and
muttered to herself she said
i knew that would happen
when it because it curdled
but the way she said it
knew that would happen but just to
herself right just to herself not to
anyone else but it was such a
cute nerdy little yeah yeah so telling
it was such a revealing
moment when i think of her i also think
of
uh how much our mother loves her oh my
god for a variety of reasons one because
she's on
her favorite show veep and correct me if
i'm wrong but she would always at least
to me
say i would love for you to meet someone
like that anna schlomsky yeah she would
never say her yeah as much as she loved
her she never bothered to learn how to
prop how to pronounce the hard ch the
klumsky it's klumsky and i would correct
her every time and she was so excited i
was working with her because oh maybe
you know maybe sparks will fly yeah
sparks will fly with shlumsky
because she really fit the mold too for
she was catholic yep uh czech extremely
intelligent
pretty yeah uh on a great show she had
an energy that my mom i think really
liked you know that kind of like upbeat
like you know
anna's very it's present present yeah
and an alert alert yeah she's an alert
energy that's true but unfortunately uh
sparks never flew between justin and
anna because she's married to a really
great guy sparks did fly between me and
her uh uh daughter
um penelope who was one of my favorite
names too penny was like let's clarify
how old her daughter is i one for the
disturbed audience she's really one
uh she she was so cute and um yeah i had
so much fun with her uh she was one and
i talked about that we talked about it
and oddly enough sparks flew between
anna's husband sean and our brother
damian yeah they really hit it off and
our brother is
heterosexual he's married to a wonderful
woman
you could have fooled me that night he
was i know he was like was this the
night that we all learned something
including him you know this is a new
thing for him and he kept bringing him
up later ah man that shawn is so so they
had such massive non-sexual crushes on
on one another
um so
for those who don't know she is
former child star she was in the movie
my girl with macaulay culkin and then my
girl two
um and now she's a
multiple emmy nominated
uh actress many many times over i mean
emmy nominated yeah the point where
that's almost overshadowed i mean you
have to mention that because it's not
like oh she's the girl from my girl name
i mean it's something that's been
overshadowed i'm sure she's very happy
about that by this by her success as an
an adult um my girl wasn't i was i think
just a little too old for it to be like
a seminal
really yeah that was my age yeah my girl
she was a little kid she was like 10
years old as was i at the time so
i remember that movie so well so i
remember meeting her and thinking is
this is so bizarre that she's this
person that i
knew you know when i was a little kid
and we were the same age so you feel a
sort of connection with with her because
of that we're the same age yeah it would
be weird to meet like the guy who played
a trey you in never-ending story or like
weird or like fred savage someone like
that would oh my god that would make my
brain melt oh my god i worked with with
winnie cooper wow and danica mckellar
who was i was playing this brainiac this
like mathematician and she played the
kind of ditzy sweet cheerleader next
door but in life in actuality danica was
a brilliant mathematician and i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a titsy you know so it was a
real role reversal with dan mckellar but
i couldn't get past that she was winnie
cooper it was so indelible that show was
such an indelible part of my channel so
that's a bit how i feel about my girl
too without you i mean the sequel or my
girl as well
this straight to video my girl three
that anna wasn't in
still my girl
it was nice to see her and it was
because we had had so much fun working
on that play with um with the now
corrupted renee fleming uh and so it was
it was great to see her and talk to her
and i hope you guys enjoy it so we'll be
right back with anna klumsky or shlomsky
as my mother would say uh right after
the break
i haven't pulled out the clarinet for
like a year
but
but i do play it i don't play it as well
as when i when i was sort of we're in a
room that is uh that it says this is a
really cool like music it's a music room
um there's piano there's a bunch of
instruments but there's a
sax trumpet yeah there there's it looks
like there's two alto sax's a trumpet
mclaren what were you saying and so you
played the clarinet i played the
clarinet and then i played tenor sax for
for
jazz band but clarinet was my love so
you were like
you you're right
you're a real like a real nerd yeah i'm
a real nerd what were you saying um
you're pouring milk and you were saying
something yourself i said to myself this
is gonna curdle because i know that
brand and it always curdles and yet i
continued to make the choice
i don't know why it was something funny
about that um commenting on the curdling
to yourself to get back to the nerdiness
of you did i still talk to myself yeah
yeah there's something really that's an
only child thing isn't it oh maybe yeah
maybe because you are i have a half
brother but we didn't grow up together i
almost said you were an only child but
you remain in only one only child
and then i gained a half brother but we
are the only of our of our um combos
but this is interesting and this is
something that you learned much later oh
which that i oh no no well he was born
14 years after i was oh oh okay yeah oh
i see yes i learned i learned okay
because it happened
you were there okay it wasn't some like
scandal i learned it as he was born it
wasn't a klumsky family like no there
were others other plenty other of those
okay well we'll get to that oh geez
don't give them the satisfaction that
side of the family be so happy that
they're being talked about like no
there's some other accent that's coming
out now uh
where are you other than chica other
than that
okay yeah chicago okay yeah it just came
out a little bit did it well because
we're talking about my family my family
yeah that's what happened that's right
you're gonna do this the whole time i'm
sorry sorry it's fine it's just that's
gonna be what you have is this bringing
you back to uh we did a play together um
and this is about five years ago now
yeah
is it five yeah this summer it'll be
five years because uh penny is penny was
had her first year birthday there this
is your first child penny and now you
have two um but we did a play it was
called living on love wait what did you
say you have two yeah i have two i
thought you said you had two oh no no i
like i you sh like you i lost my world
down for a second i was very excited but
anyway i was like what have i i've
really been under a rock no i wouldn't i
know you wish i know your child and the
time that we spent together penny back
then was is one of those kids that makes
you really wish you had kids you know
yeah i used to say she was she was birth
control repellent is that what i used to
anyway yeah yeah exactly yes exactly
yeah she is and some kids are not some
kids you're like i don't need this i
don't need this in my life
so when we were doing the play my mother
um i learned something about my mother
which is that she's obsessed with you
what i thought you knew this i don't
well maybe i kept her away from you a
little well that might be also if you
told me i'm horrible at accepting
compliments so it's not like you didn't
internalize that right that's right so
when people say to you
i love your work how what does that do
what's the psychological process that
thank them in the moment and i'm
grateful for that well you know like i'm
especially if it's somebody who um
is is genuinely appreciative of the work
then i really then it's then you're
getting each other and then you're like
yay great and yeah you feel good you
feel good right as opposed to like some
you know i want a photo yeah it smells
like a get yeah you know yeah um but but
yeah i'm grateful in the moment and but
but you know very rarely do do the
compliments live live yeah
what if it's from somebody who you whom
you admire
oh if it's somebody those stay yeah they
say you remember those yeah
yeah you remember those but then you
kind of were like did that happen and am
i allowed to remember that yeah
there's a whole
who's your who give me give me one that
lives in you oh
this is so it's so embarrassing saying
things like this out loud
but no one's listening that's well so
far
no um
uh well no okay so backstage uh at you
can't take it with you
um
tom hanks
that's thomas hanks yeah i don't yeah
i'm i'm assuming oh you call him tom
because you mentioned him i call him
thomas i met him once uh oh no and i met
him twice i guess yeah but um but no but
this was the so yeah he was backstage
and he was so dear he said um
he was like oh you're i think he said oh
you're tiny because i'm short uh-huh and
you're surprised
no i but but but yeah i'm not like some
but i'm but you're taller than you were
in my girl i get well this is i guess
yes indeed um
but i guess just barely no but um but he
anyway and so i think he saw my face
going oh yeah i am short but and he went
well you cast um you cast a wide shadow
that's awesome right that's cool and
then he and then he got nervous that
maybe he thought i was talking about
like my size yeah and he was like i need
that as a compliment i'm like oh i'm
taking it
as a compliment what did you get i mean
i that's cool and that he had just seen
you and in a play that i loved doing
that's that's cool
that's really cool he i you know his
kindness is legendary but yeah but he
didn't have to say that no of course no
just the fact that he came and yeah yeah
it was really cool i i um i've probably
told this story before but i i was doing
a job once and and uh
this is years ago and uh the pa that i
worked closely with was like at the end
of the shoot was like justin good luck
to every you know i hope you
good luck in your career and like i hope
you don't i hope if anything ever
happens and your career takes off i hope
you don't become one of these like tom
hanks types wow yeah complimenting
people and touching their careers i know
and i wake up
i was like i should only i should be so
lucky
by the way pa is production assistant i
just wanted literally yes oh yeah
audience now oh they know
know it's my mom and my brother they
know i said well it's tom hanks
[Music]
okay and she said no no he's a diva he's
this and that my first instinct was like
oh she's a production assistant she's
seen it all she's seen it all she's like
and and she was the base camp which
means that oh well yeah so i was like oh
god maybe she saw behind the curtain and
she saw like real behavior had a bad day
exactly
a job sometimes you just jab
that's what i said that so i thought
okay when he was having a bad day and i
asked her to explain what had happened
and she said i said oh you worked with
him she said no no i ran into him i was
with a friend of mine and he wouldn't
take him we were we were on the
promenade santa monica promenade and we
said oh
you're telling me we get it on it would
take a picture or something and he said
and he rolled his eyes and he turned to
his wife and said like i'm doing right
now anyway yeah and said um i told you
we shouldn't come here
and and i was like and that was it that
was the end of the story and i was like
and it was it was disappointing and i
thought
i said well maybe he was just like you
know all these people maybe he had been
bothered a lot that day because he was
in a touristy area and she said as an
afterthought she said
yeah well it turns out that's what
happened because then he we walked a
couple blocks and he ran back up to us
ran back up to us
and begged for our forgiveness and
signed stuff and took photo and i said
wait wait wait wait wait what she chose
to should
like to keep
isn't that scary it was a lesson pillow
would have some things to say
yes yes yes but anyway it was a lesson
it's not that he would he already does
but he doesn't you know have to
aggrandize his ego by saying something
about somebody else's i mean yeah i've
obviously read a book yeah you have just
about the power of now i actually didn't
read that one i read the earth one oh
okay the earth's one where he talks
about the earth being flat the newer yes
yeah the new earth
the new alder i remember reading across
being like oh my god i would have to
read certain things like
four or five times i'd have to leave
some of it alone for a little bit it's
so profound and i know it's gonna do so
much good it's true it's totally true
but i'm
really freaked out
it's freaky but it's also like i know
this is so valuable for my life and my
well-being my psychological well-being
and and i then uh two days later i
forget it yeah two days maybe two hours
later yeah yeah
but that's just how i am that's why
oprah keeps reading rereading it oh
really yeah like anyway i just realized
oh that's why you reread things first i
want to go to your name i'm sorry i'm
jumping around your name what do people
usually call you do they get your name
wrong often oh my last name both hell
yeah yeah well yeah it's funny it is
funny that they even get the first name
wrong that's true well i mean but any
that just goes to show you that anybody
could get any name wrong i mean anna's
pretty darn simple but there are a lot
of people call me
there are a lot of honors yeah they'll
call me anna and that's fine and when
and if i'm in brazil it's anna so oh it
is yeah i you know i introduce myself as
ana maria when i'm in brazil because
that's because there's so many honors
you just you always tack on the middle
name you casually mention brazil but we
should we should get to that uh you
spend it
oh yes oh yeah we do we do uh oh and
it's klumsky yes it's like christmas
people ch does exist as a cure so we
might need to edit this somehow but my
mother can not to make it all about my
mother oh i think i remember this yes
okay so my mother
as much as she loves you and i'm not
exaggerating she really does um
she could not get your last name right
and to this day yeah when she talks to
me about you she i was like yeah i mean
remember rihanna tomorrow she's like oh
yeah a lot of people say schlemsky
um but she wouldn't just say she would
go she would even get the ski wrong
she'd go
oh my gosh she looked like it was all
schlum
it's a messy messy ass name like i do
not i do not take no i don't it's
actually the same
physical
activity as clearing your throat
yeah it's not great yeah did you ever
have an agent who was like hey if you
really want to make it in this biz no
but my mom and i wanted to change it to
several different things but i mean we
didn't what was that
we were just bullshitting i mean oh can
i i don't know okay [ __ ] yeah
yeah um you can't laugh though oh sorry
no that's i've been told that my whole
life that's a hell of a laugh you just
heard how loud my laugh is uh after
let's just call it it's offensive to
many it's a cackle it's a chemical for
sure i i am discovering all of my
witchiness in in my at the beginning of
my middle age but um it's a great laugh
some people laugh with um they're i
watch the bachelor a lot and they often
laugh with like a like they're
self-conscious it's it's a laugh it's
you have a band it's a it's a for people
laugh i
this is the thing with the laughs though
it's like i realized you know i have
issues with social you know interactions
and i realized sometimes
i asked somebody else the other day they
were like oh i you know i i made her
this person laugh and then
some people like looked at us for
whatever reason and she's like oh they
just looked at us because i laughed loud
and i went are you a loud laugher and
she's like yeah and i was like do you
find
that you feel that you're just your
essence is like
invasive to others because you've always
been shushed for joy
and she's like
i never thought of that that way but
you've given me a lot to think about
some people are shushed for
banging on pots or like yeah clearly
negative stuff doing things they
shouldn't do but like farting i'm
laughing which is yeah an expression of
joy sure speaking of gay you were raised
uh roman catholic yes
um how's that for a segue huh
you say what you will about this podcast
pretty much
speaking of gay and then be like anna
klumsky's upbringing sure like that
actually makes sense um
does it were you surrounded by a lot of
gay yeah yeah yeah all like a lot of my
father figures growing up because your
problem was
yeah so like a lot of like
a lot of my father figures were lovely
lovely gay men so your mom did a lot of
musical theater then yeah and so yeah
and i did too and so that's yeah oh you
did when you were a kid yeah oh wow
so how because my mom was an actress too
and and i remember going
to those auditions and being you
probably had the opposite reaction where
it it became something you wanted to
participate in i wanted nothing i wanted
to
participate in theater what she was
doing yeah she was doing shows with her
singing and dancing and on stage and
that was fun yeah um i wasn't as into
having to do the modeling
jobs where people are like sticking you
with pins and pulling your hair and like
telling you to stare into the sun did
you voice that did you
yeah
and did she continue did she she
listened she was pretty good about she
was like a first stage mommy for all the
pitfalls and we definitely got into him
yeah um of a professional life for a kid
like
she did her very very best and that's
something she did right when she
listened to me when i
said that i was over certain things and
and
the things that she did wrong that you
can talk about
um
were they things that you were able to
get past when you were a kid were were
they things that just required commute
more communication no i don't think so i
think that the pitfalls that we fell
into had very much to do with her
psychology and programming and and my
dad's and yeah and what did your dad do
my dad um was a restaurant uh was a
restaurant owner and chef oh no yeah he
was he had a previous life as a musician
but that's
but yeah um during all that i saw some
pictures of him he had an incredible
mustache
my dad is a philosophy professor has had
a beard his whole life yeah i've never
seen his face yeah i i've no yeah i've
seen pictures of my dad
in the 60s before he had it but that's
it but it is fascinating to me uh the
idea of having such a
um
an upbringing where you are uh
you are you are
lauded and you were looked at in a
certain way by adults you were you sure
you were you were put in the spotlight
did you ever feel a sense of competition
with people and you're a kid i mean how
could you no but that's that's one of
the things i really don't like about
professional uh i mean and kids feel
competitive no matter what you're sure
anything i was competitive about how
much soda i was drinking
kids are like this because they just are
just searching for the the the right
limits and there's you know and then
they want to be the best at something
because it makes them feel more secure
and what they're doing and they want
their parents to be you know yes and
then there's the parents approval
teachers approval but you don't have
siblings so you don't have to contend
with that at least no but you still want
approval sure i still want approval and
i do think you know in retrospect i
think like living in two different homes
you know like my parents got divorced
when i was two oh okay so i do think
there's a sense of
approval
that happens there
whose approval was more important to you
i mean dad for sure yeah because was it
harder to come by as a kid um he was
very he was very spoiling like he loved
he you know when i was around my dad
like it was very much like here's like
it was lavishing pretty you spent less
time with him but i spent less time with
him yeah yeah he didn't raise me yeah
yeah okay and but but both in chicago
both your parents were okay yeah until
he moved and then he moved when i was
seven he moved to indiana and we would
drive there and then he moved when i was
10 to wisconsin which correlated oh
boy uh-oh correlate i have therapy on
friday uh well let's just do it now uh
with that because you're qualified sure
um yeah no but yeah so he moved to
wisconsin
uh the same year like the same time as
my girl oh really yeah a lot of that
restaurant in wisconsin
it was very wrapped up in
being the girl for my girl as well
because it was rough i bet so you're
contending with uh this big life change
my dad is moving further away
and i imagine when you go there to visit
him is there any this is my girl from my
girl yeah yeah and that's gotta feel
even more alienated there's a lot yeah
i can't i'm proud i can't relate to that
but um i'm excited to talk to you after
therapy
no i've been working on this one for a
while
i bet well you're a kid but i admire you
more [ __ ] like we all have something
that made that has made us how that we
are today and that's yes
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
okay okay so you do so okay first of all
i'm on uncle buck uh
do you meet macaulay culkin yeah
well no i didn't meet me okay okay so
matt so you call mac so then you meet so
what is the process like for my girl
then we'll move on to my girl too
no sorry
um
my girl was
i was put on tape and then howard the
the director came to chicago
and then he um
and then i went to
la to test and that was when i met mac
okay yeah so you had like a chemistry
thing yeah like it comes through yeah
screen test and chemistry read were you
nervous to meet him he was already a big
star i think i was a little bit but i
it's funny i think i was more nervous to
meet him than it was ever to meet adults
yeah yeah i bet yeah you know because
again like
kids were
my source of agita
right yeah because i yeah cause because
those are your peers and your company
yeah and i but also that's who i
couldn't please
do you know what i mean whereas like
adults were easy
because kids looked at you like you were
in there why does she think she's so
special
you know like and because i was like the
young i mean this is classification
stuff i was thinking
i don't even know about that i just
think i mean i was i was the littlest
because i started kindergarten early and
so i just i was always the one who
ruined a team
you know oh come on anna you can't oh
boy you know like i mean classic i mean
everybody had you know not everybody but
many people have something where i was
always yeah picked last blah blah blah
sure we're in show biz yeah um but how
did you respond to that as a kid were
you then desperate to make friendships
or were you like all right well then
[ __ ] you i'm gonna go i think it's both
right it's like
they they're mad at me or whatever and
then it's like but you know i wish they
weren't i wish that i was good enough
for them the girls mostly right i mean
girls and boys
and
um yeah like i wish i was good enough
for them but i'm not and so then screw
them or you know what i mean so yeah
it's it's both when you're the little
but i say this to my kids because
they're little too and i'm like little
little body big brain yeah you'll find
your value in in other ways and then i
wonder if that's why you
talk to yourself sometimes still and say
like oh milk is curdled because you
spent a lot of time then on your own
maybe
oh definitely yeah i had a many barbies
because i was a girl and like one and i
was like the only one of my generation
in my family so they so lots of people
would buy me barbies
um i mean i had an elaborate elaborate
world with my barbies and i used like
rug samples as their as theirs um like
you were a barbie girl in a barbie world
yeah oh i loved that song are you
kidding what song
but yeah and so like my dad had a copy
machine because it was a restaurant for
menus and stuff so i would copy their
faces and make little ids for all of my
barbies
and i would laminate them with scotch
tapes they were actually like ids and so
that anybody who came to play with me
like could catch up and like know who
they all were
and know where they were in the story i
know that is very right brain that's
very amy from veep oh god it i guess it
is except just a little more creative i
think she'd be like f these barbies well
i mean child amy yeah not adulting me
yeah she'd be
maybe maybe that's who i'm she should be
maybe but she but yeah and so then but
like it was you know there was there was
the family that like
had a unwanted pregnancy and then there
were you know the skipper had an
unwanted pregnancy and that's dark yeah
it was super awful and like you know
there was oh yeah she was pregnant which
was fine but then her husband kept
cheating on her and then
they
sell they live next to the college so
they subletted to this college guy again
and i don't remember what i named him
brian or something and then he
impregnated the 13 year old daughter
she's rough and then so oh no she wasn't
even a daughter oh [ __ ] so this is what
i i'd like the audience to know that
you're raising your you just raised your
hand
you we're seated across from each other
and you please interrupt myself like
teacher i have the answer
i'm seeing middle i'm seeing at school
so anna yeah it's fine
um oh yeah so she was the niece what did
you just say by the way i'm sorry i said
i could tell this story in portuguese
that's what i said yeah okay but yeah so
she knows she was a niece because this
is what happened so i had one that was
not actually a barbie it looked like she
had hair plugs you know it was like it's
kind of cheaply so what i did was i
fixed a bottle to her hand and she was
like the village alcoholic
oh my god you definitely didn't tell me
this story i didn't no
uh that's fascinating how old were you
when you were doing this 10
20 29 10
which is yeah at that same time wow but
yeah so this is at the same time as it's
like
my girl wisconsin all of it yeah so
and like uh you know like
unfortunately my mom was dating somebody
i didn't you know like mike yeah all of
it oh my god
so this maybe was your way of exercising
mostly likely okay my life is bad and
difficult to figure out not bad but like
my jerry springer yeah yeah for sure but
it could be and i can manage these i can
manage these lives
have ids and organize them and be like
no village alcoholic you don't get to
keep custody of your 13 year old she's
going to live with your sister but then
she's going to get impregnated by the
college sub letter what a creative
interesting way to work out what
psychologically poor little you was
going through
seriously i guess i mean what a healthy
way to do it i think so this is post
you're 10 my girl's out you're known oh
that's what i was going to say and this
was again by the grace of my mom's
decisions was like i saw a taste of what
it is to be put out there for you know
to the wolves but like i did not
have to deal with that the way that a
lot of those kids did right certainly
the way mac certainly and like that yeah
did you learn anything from watching how
that affected him yeah i i couldn't i
mean i i learned to to hate mobs i
learned
you know and to distrust the concept of
fanship and stuff you know because he
would i mean
they would just they they would they
would pull at her hair and they would
put i mean it was just
it's not okay and and so yeah it's so i
think his story's so unique and again
not mine to tell but like but even other
kids but what you have a lot more a lot
tougher than i did too like i got to
stay home i got to be in the band and
you know play clarinet and know what
that's about and like i'm so happy that
that's what i got to do i i worked with
brad renfrow about 20 years ago brad was
a kid who came up around the time you
did and um was really special brad was
so good in that movie he's so good and
and earnest and right he was arrested
every time i hear the whole whole like
plucked from the streets kind of crap i
just shudder i just shudder well
because i get nervous of course yeah but
but i'm saying that's
and i'm sure you do now appreciate but i
get nervous when kids aren't plucked
from the streets either do you know what
i mean because it's like oh they've been
going through the mill they know the
process which is horrible they have
resumes like now yeah either way i
shudder i'll put it that way so you're
keeping your kids away from yeah until
they're 18. come on until i mean they
can make their own no i i
um
i'm going to get plenty wrong because
parents we we're going to get plenty
wrong like that's just but something i
really um
really value in raising my kids is just
knowing that they are not me they are
not extensions of me or my own person
you know
like
it's very rare experience and they're
they are their own human beings and um
and i love that about them yeah it's i
think that's harder to preserve that
idea on with social media because
i i have seen i've noticed that a lot of
people
use their kids to us to do varying
degrees on social media as extensions i
think social media is just another way
to show it i think they've always done
it sure i mean i i mean
and listen you think your parents did it
to a degree yeah yeah i think i i think
i got the lucky end yeah but um but i
but but also like
this is a kind of
a a human evolutionary thing in that you
know originally you had kids to help you
in the farm yeah so like they were to be
you that's true they were you know and
so true now they have you to help uh you
know solidify their their public
personas and and you know oh god uh push
whatever social agenda they're they're
yeah right
terrifying that's terrifying but that's
but i do think that but that's something
that i i do always keep in mind and
again i don't know i
i don't necessarily like extensions of
me i like other people yeah
that's something like it's just nice
because they're like oh wow who are you
you're amazing yeah you know and and
hoping that you they're soaking up the
good things and the you know who knows
who i can't they're at school half the
day you know like i don't know what
they're you know what i mean like you
can do your best but you have to just
allow them to you have to was that hard
to let them like penelope is now full
she's five she's in kindergarten she's
so cute i still have video like it's so
creepy i have videos of your daughter on
my phone okay it's really weird as a
one-year-old
it's really weird i would just like
it's funny i now see parents doing that
and i like roll my eyes and i did it
with it somebody wasn't even my kid i
know we skipped we skipped matt so mac
you work with them
dan aykroyd what was was he was he like
a dad a big cuddly dad he was but he had
his own kids too and you know what i
mean and yeah um no it was fine it was
all it was three months of my life
making that movie and then it was
another three months of my life making
the other ones so okay you know so it
wasn't that
did you feel nervous on set when you
were like counting no i did not feel
nervous wow i um no i didn't i
so then when you came back to school
after the movie after you shoot the
movie yeah are you like oh boy i'm
sitting on this thing and just wait for
a few in a few months i guess a little
bit i think i didn't understand that
until
um i think my team like my teacher yeah
um
sort of knew
you know she i think she kind of knew
[ __ ] was going to change yeah um you
co-starred with one of the biggest stars
and people were obsessed with him back
yeah so yeah it was
yeah there was a lot of like
ex you know like yeah i mean that's all
the way to today when people ask me
about then when we were 10.
they're trying to get to something else
through me and it's all a very
objectifying experience yeah
and talking about it is also
you know also runs the the risk of being
very objectifying just because it's like
you can't i can't be the thing for
whomever's asking me the question like
you if you if a you know somebody like
asks and again morning talk shows ask
about it much more and i think there's a
reason it's because they can't watch you
know like people a lot of the time
people watching a morning show probably
can't watch feet but yeah um because of
the swearing um but
but it's it is i mean it's like because
that's not you 28 years yeah
you're just like i can't yeah i can't
possibly be that thing well this is a
perfect segue to more my girl questions
um
uh so so you go back to school so
but what is your so we talked about
wisconsin and and everything's in
changing turmoil you're
you're becoming i mean not turmoil maybe
but it is trauma it's a trauma it's a
trauma if you use the word the other day
i used that word and somebody's like
really anna sometimes it can be so not
and i was like trauma can be both good
and bad it's a traumatic for an adult
it's just me all trauma me like
childbirth is the most beautiful thing
in the entire world that i've
experienced and it's still traumatic
because
basic my best shorthand for deciding on
what is a trauma or not is um is if you
define
things as before and after that event
post uh pmg post my girl yeah yeah and
then b mg um
we can edit something else in later um
so p so pmg
you go on i'm confused
[Music]
you do a couple more movies uh after my
girl you do gold diggers yeah the legend
of bear mountain
in which uh by the way a great cast in
that ritchie is here draper well
probably no probably yeah
it didn't wasn't
andre the giant
he was in mommy markets which then was
called trading mom trading mom yeah yeah
and your mom was also in that small part
yeah and she was just she was in my girl
too she was in my girl too that's right
i mean as well as well not my girl t-o-o
no no no my girl oh not my girl she was
in the first one she was in the first
line
so so you're getting to do these movies
it must is it like
camp is it like uh do you how do you see
a little bit it depends it was nice when
it was during the summer yeah um because
then you're not missing any homework you
can invite like sometimes i invited
friends you know which was really fun
and they treat you so well on themselves
yeah
um my mom was also really good about
that like she you know thank god she was
just like no like
yeah like there was a day that she
caught me not saying please and it was
like and she and she actually berated
also like the the production assistants
the pa and being like
do not get her anything do not let her
order you around do not you know and i'm
so like that's told like yes that's um
good yeah even in the moment i wasn't
like come on mom i was like oh yeah yep
wow would you witness i'm sure you
witnessed behavior you know that that
kind of behavior from cancer you meet a
lot of shitty yeah yeah yeah and and at
the time when you're now a teenager or a
preteen can you re do you recognize that
as being shitty
yes and also and that's the other thing
is like my i mean you know i yeah i was
at that you know yeah
that's i guess another sort of i don't
know if it's a if it's a continuation
first of all we should say the trauma of
the first one and possibly the entire
sort of part of that career yeah is that
everybody starts treating you
differently when you go back home even
your family and so that's like why
that's the big difference was just like
i was just anna before and now i am
um at fourth of july and i've got to do
autographs for a whole bunch of people's
friends and i've got to go and meet
so-and-so and da da and it's just that's
what's bizarre is you become you go from
being a kid in your in your extended
family to a commodity to a commodity i
remember
currency you just your currency
everywhere you go your value lies not in
who you are in what in this thing that
you did months ago with the right
and no one bothers
to find out anything it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because they've got
their thing yeah they don't mean it no
no bless them they don't mean it they're
excited oh my god but
of course but that's what it does and so
that's the and that is also why as an
adult i do get
very um
i don't know like touchy when i talk
about it because it's like i always say
on like again on the morning talk shows
i'm like you can ask about it but are
you ready for a therapy session yeah
exactly yeah
i'll talk about it yeah but it ain't
cute fortunately on this i am ready for
a therapy session
yeah no but that's something that people
should know i mean i especially parents
of kids who want to do this i mean it's
incredible the amount of people that i
go and i'm like how are you as a kid
yeah and they're like i don't want to
talk about it yeah and you're like yeah
so you take time off you two and how
much of that time off was a response to
what you're talking about now exactly
yeah cause it because so then we go to
my girl two which now you're going
through puberty yeah you ain't cute
anymore yeah
no one is i mean word no i'm 13 years
old and it's like it's zit city
and i'm developing and that looks like
fat on camera so
they start monitoring my food
and they yeah and it was and it was a
studio movie now because now you know
before it was like under the radar now
it's like it's on the lot
and so they're high stakes and yeah
in a way you're being that role too
i mean i know it's a kid's movie but
you're the ongenu word you're the leader
yeah they were trying to do that with
the kisses and with the thing you know
and it's just like
so like they were trying to toe a line
between like innocent like kids getting
together and like coming of age or
something yeah there's romance yeah so
it's like yeah exactly which was bizarre
and so it's for me but i bet because you
even is that your i mean in terms of
kissing boys and like my first yeah the
first one was my girl but then and then
and we were just like this is ridiculous
right you laughed about it we did it
it's ridiculous yeah and then but then
the second yeah then like the second
it's
i don't know because then there was more
it's like
the nice thing was with the with at
least the story of the first one it was
them beings being kids whereas the sec
was the next one is them actually like
you said having like a romance or
something which is bizarre you got to
witness how
superficial yeah
which again i think was a great teacher
absolutely so when you get back into
acting it's for the
as they say on the bachelor the right
reasons i always say that do they say
that on the path i've never watched an
episode of it so i'm like
i'm missing all your references i'm
sorry i'm sorry yeah i only referenced
you represented about like three times
it's okay hey
um so yeah you so you take time off you
step away and and
was that in response to
just not
enjoying it
definitely and also not enjoying how it
made me feel because all of high school
was basically trying and trying and
trying and not and you know just putting
myself on tape like crazy and not
getting anything because i didn't know
what i was doing because a high school
kid doesn't know and
you know and then it also of course it
was always
they always told me it was because of my
my weight or and then you felt very
competitive it was just it was just
awful and so
once i got to college university of
chicago you went yes and
i i think the whole first year i was
still sort of pursuing it because i
always knew that's you know like i was
like that's what i promised what you've
known that's what i've known yeah and
and i
you know went i like went on another
audition that i like didn't wasn't gonna
get and i like through the sides those
are the the pages
that you read when of a script when you
audition i threw the sides on my
passenger seat of my car and i almost
had like a little bit of an out of body
where i just kind of like pulled back
and just sort of like saw this like saw
them and kept them there and i went ah i
don't have to do that those aren't mine
yeah i don't have to do this anymore
and i don't have to feel this way
anymore you're just you're
disassociating yourself from
that thing that activity been a part of
your identity like again what a gift
because
then when i got back into it i knew that
that was [ __ ] like i would have
adults being like well so and so said
that i had to lose weight and i'd be
like [ __ ] them yeah yeah because i've
been through that and no well also you
went through it in during the most
vulnerable part of your lifetime
but but also you're making that decision
you're having that out-of-body
experience while you're at this
wonderful wonderful
to this day i see it i like going on
campus and i feel so happy
because i just it's because it's it was
safety it was the first time i think i
ever felt safe and and
with that was there a sense of joe
happening i mean
yeah yeah and listen i cried a lot yeah
because you're still in college and
you're freaking out and there's boys and
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh
but one in particular well yeah yeah
yeah this is where you met sean i had
sean there who is a fascinating man in
his own right uh
you should have him on this podcast i
know i by the way i would love to oh my
god um sean was in well you talked
i mean i don't know how much to tell
about that i guess yeah i mean i suppose
well no it just here's a job you can't
really talk about
i mean used to yeah and now you can and
everything's out but he no he's um he's
a veteran and he's uh and he's a
business owner and um an awesome dad he
climbed mountains for a little bit he's
very he's outdoorsy he's familiar
training for a triathlon he was not cia
oh he wasn't no i thought he was no he
wasn't he wasn't culinary institute of
america yeah right the culinary
institute um no he was he worked for the
defense department but he wasn't
intelligence when he was in the army
reserve but that's okay that's overt in
afghanistan
yes but that's over that's not covert
okay okay um and and so
you're experiencing college you're
having a relatively now because you're
kind of out of the business relatively
normal i think it's probably the most
yeah the most like
uh i don't want to say i i i i
i started to become loathe to say the
word normal because i realize none of us
are normal right right i shouldn't have
said that no i'm oh i'm and i'm also not
chastising you fruit no but you are not
abnormal no but yeah just i guess but
you're having a more
a less unique customary yeah yeah yeah
yeah like
and and
and during that time definitely less
public definitely less public and were
there remnants of that public like like
sure i mean yeah people would be like
the girl from america yeah like i was on
the scav hunt you know list one year the
university of chicago has a famous scav
hunt
scavenger hunt every year and i was on
that list as like not like just as
somebody to like take a picture oh like
no i know life could be a dream
[Music]
what has that been like getting to watch
julia louis dreyfus like regularly
i mean i it's been a joy she's awesome
she's she's um i'm trying to like not
give you
my pet answers yeah no no justin well
here's the thing i
love there's some many things that
fascinate me about her but
she strikes me as somebody who has such
a good sense of humor that i would be
i'm nervous to meet her i i'd be nervous
to be around her
yeah i mean i value that
more than anything i think that happens
to her a lot yeah and i think that
people are intimidated by her yeah and i
and i also
you know but
but yeah i
i
i don't know she's she's so warm and
loving um but i think that
yeah i think that um
that it's it's hard for people to get
over their own expectations yeah do you
know any abs i have them yeah such high
ones and right um and she should she's
phenomenal
you you work after college you work
you worked as a fact checker for zaggett
yeah did you say zager is a guy it's
zagat rhymes with the cat
i mean seriously the prayers were like
god just give me a job and that's where
i know you're gonna send me like i know
that's your sign of where i'm going next
and so the zagat was the job that i got
okay right here i am in new york what
did you major in again i i
majored in international studies which
is international relations
yeah um
so yeah so i move here
and i think i'm going to be a fiction
writer
um so you wrote a lot and i think i'm
going to be a travel writer because i i
feel like i've i'm a type like i mean
any you know there's many
many a young lady who reads you know
what color's your parachute and fills
out all the worksheets and goes i am
going to be a travel and food writer
yeah and also
still i would love that doing those you
can write so of course this is my
comment i'm going to write about naps
i'm so good at it
so so yeah but if you're napping anyway
what so then and at this point you're
with sean you're with your husband he
gets deployed for two years to
afghanistan he did one year in
afghanistan but because of deployment
it's it's it takes uh it takes a certain
amount of time yeah so he so
so from 2002 to 2004
i was working in publishing in some ways
either zagat or harper collins and then
i
um had and then at that same time so
around 2003-ish
um my then boyfriend now husband um
decided to um enlist
and in army reserve
so he was training so he was there when
i kind of had my like epiphany
that i wanted to try acting again huh
and how did that happen do you remember
i had a bunch of different friends sort
of kind of like you know if i'm sad i'm
like i'm sad and love you yeah and it's
like well you know you need to i had a i
had a great friend named steve baker who
um was in kung fu with me and he like he
was literally like you know what your
problem is it wasn't was like kung fu
class yeah i was in a kung fu school oh
i forget kung fu thing
right
right you were in kung fu
after college yeah oh cool i did i did
like shotokan karate in college because
they didn't have kung fu i wanted to be
michelle yo basically oh yeah i think
the thing is like it was it was sort of
on my shoulder
um and i was trying to ignore it because
i had seen mercedes rule in
edward albee's um the goat or who is
sylvia
and i was like
what she's amazing um i tell sometimes
roberta flack story where i was like
getting my nails done and roberta flack
was at the nail salon and they
introduced me to her you were like the
first time ever i saw your
nail that's right and she was like and
she and she somehow she said she knew
who i was which i was like come on
well why wouldn't she wouldn't mean come
on well i don't know i'm like come from
a silly movie attendant you know like
100 years ago whatever wildly popular i
i guess so but for me i could see flak
like in that like i could yeah she said
she did she didn't give her flag for she
also could be saying anything she wants
i don't
but anyway but she was very kind classic
she said the point is she's yeah classic
um but no but she's she was so kind and
she um but then she was like what are
you doing now and i was like oh no i'm
done i've given it all up i'm not i
don't i don't do that anymore and she
looked at me with like one of those kind
of like like
really you know like kind of like just
like almost like she gave you flat she
gave me some flex yeah and not but in
the eyes she never would she was like
okay
like she was like that she's like okay
and i was like oh no like i'm
disappointed she it's like she saw your
truth it kind of was yeah
and
and so then that was so that stuck with
me and then you know and and there was
another she said you should get back in
deflecting yes
i was like
i can't
stomach the idea of being a grandmother
with my grandkid on my knee
telling her that she should pursue her
dreams
and she look up to me and say is that
what you did grandma and i would say no
i didn't but you should
yeah i wanted to be a living example
yeah
so what is it like then starting from
you have this extensive resume it's not
like you're
fresh out of tish and you're like yeah
but just kind of but kind of because i
didn't know what i was doing because i
because as a kid and i don't believe
like kids should not go to acting school
right they're already truthful by nature
you go to acting sure to remember who
you were as a kid and so i went let's
see and then the first day of acting
class i was like oh it's i'm not i'm not
giving this a year i'm giving this any
as long as it takes i love this like i
don't want to do anything but this yes
it would suck to say to your grandkid on
your knee like well i gave it to you
pursued it for a year and then i give up
yeah i know well some people some people
of course yeah but i but that's but i
loved it i just loved it and it was it
was just heaven and i and i learned so
much and i learned it in a summer i did
an intensive i think i'm not even going
to pretend that i did more i um but i
was ready i was already 24. i needed to
get back in but yeah then i did 10 10
free plays back to back just
going on things you know back i was
looking backstage and so then i was
broke and i was freaking out just like
anybody of course doing this then i got
sag harbor then i got uh then i got my
first equity gig oh my god and did and
then the domino and then and then at
least i could pay some rent and then i
could yeah and there and there was like
a little movie i did in indy that paid
me enough for me to get into the the sag
health insurance team
so i at least didn't have to worry about
that it's amazing that that was a
concern of yours at the time
i would have thought god residuals and
my girl and all these big movies
just said wow that's enough for like a
dinner every month that's crazy yeah and
then i finally got a lawn order wow
which is the new york thing
and then you you know and then you and i
got a 30 rock
and then i got a pilot so then now i can
pay rent pilot pilot pilot pilot for
several years
yeah just doing the thing captain and
then
um so now you're back and then in the
loop
in the loop yeah okay okay that's what
got me to be okay because it's the same
creators right or
british
amanda yanucci
and his merry band like simon blackwell
and tony roche and the loop was directly
led to veep and
yeah for me yeah yeah so you so
veep had such pedigree behind it that
that you kind of knew it was going to be
a hit
i mean i didn't i didn't know because it
was so different it was so you know
people didn't know what it was at first
because he's so like julia louis i mean
like yeah no but well that was the key
that was what you were like oh maybe
there's something to this but you know
but arms arms
brand of satire is not um obvious yeah
you know it takes subtle it takes
somebody to be paying attention and it's
very smart this whole thing is just like
why make the lighting perfect like the
lighting isn't the lighting isn't
perfect at the state department why
should we make it perfect in our so they
don't spend a lot of time on setups the
aesthetic of it no blocking
oh really no you just got it's like
being on stage they just let you go yeah
you set up a life and then he shoots a
documentary basically like that's the
concept [ __ ] cool throughout those
seasons throughout the shows we've had
you know regime changes we have
different directors different dps so it
changed you know yeah but that was the
that first season that was the style and
so no way did i think it would be a hit
and and people like that like you like
tony hale julie i imagine they thrive in
you know everybody has a different some
people might be thrown by it because of
my you know theatrical training i felt
really comfortable yeah doing 20-minute
takes yeah
entrances and exits um is there a lot of
ad-libbing there is but not not so much
what you see on camera it's mostly done
you would do workshops
of all the episodes that's a very
armando thing really yeah like on a
stage no uh no we were doing like a
conference room in a hotel and like like
a table read but then you would like
move the tables to get it on its feet
wow and
but you're not like improving like
writing anything because you have
brilliant writers you're actually just
kind of misering it like where you're
just playing your intention yeah just
off the script wow it's awesome because
veep is so successful has been so
is there any part of you that is worried
that there may be typecasting that like
now i'm going to be amy i'm going to be
the like i definitely want to stretch
you know me i yeah you know
what type of stuff i just said you know
100 times that's so embarrassing and
that's because i don't have the best
words yet for like exactly where i am i
know you know what i mean
i just flipped him up you know what i'm
saying here's a my girl story for you
jamie curtis on all of her continuity
photos used to it was giving the finger
it was flipping the bird and i
remembered i just admired how
how well i liked the positioning of the
she gave a good finger she gave a really
good finger and so like i think i've
just
been always going for that oh
interesting is that weird no no not at
all if you could be a professional
athlete these are just quick short
questions rapid fire
um professional athlete what sport would
you play
and why
um
first of all i'm awful um athletics but
uh i feel like
dressage well that's yeah equestrian yes
yes that's true because i did ride for a
little bit yeah okay um yeah one snack
food for the rest of your life with do
you ever watch sports do sean i watch
time i'm a
that's right that's right you were
really into it yeah yeah brazil [ __ ]
that year oh that's right because you
spent how long did you spend in brazil
three years oh no not not even that long
i thought i studied abroad there in the
summer i'm afraid to ask this now what's
your favorite movie of all time
um
and you can't say gold diggers
damn it
it's perfection it's not um i um
american in paris oh yeah no kidding oh
wait who directed that that was uh that
was vincent alley it's minelli so you
like
that then that's your type of movie that
you like you you i mean i like all types
yeah certain but but
yeah the one if if they were if all the
reels were going to be
going to be wiped off
because i because it used to be singing
in the rain for the longest time oh yeah
but then and it was always like singing
in the rain and then um like i like the
godfather and then like american parents
i used to write i like ranking so yeah
oh you so you had a list yeah i did but
yeah and so yeah it's it's amazing
i know that's that's a hard question to
answer because i i love movies i
literally have a list yeah yeah that's
good so like yeah but but in that moment
i went okay if everything gets if
there's a if there's a deluge and desert
islands dvd like you know and like a
wave a huge tidal wave is gonna like
wipe off all of the all of the reels and
archives which one do you say if i save
america in paris um i have movies like
that i think i know you talked about it
where you go back it's like hanging out
with a friend um is it this is so
comforting um
you know i've never seen an american in
paris so i yeah well i hope you'll watch
it i want to now
wait because i love those two other
movies
you're singing the theme song to it yeah
the the theme song yeah
yes it's uh it's a piece that was
written by gershwin gershwin yes
uh jesus gershwin or jesus gershwin
gershwin
uh speaking of gershwin uh
do you i have a favorite woody allen do
you uh how do you what are your thoughts
on woody allen i mean not that you have
to get it political but i'm sure we've
talked about this though yeah have you
are you did you cancel him are you i i
you had i mean i i still appreciate the
movies yeah oh you okay so you're able
to watch no i it's hard for me sometimes
but this is because it's
he's
his
ills are very wrapped into some of the
postpartum depression stuff i used to
have like so yeah um and so i think you
and i did discuss this um
but
but no the i mean there's still such
phenomenal movies like there's still
great movies and that's this is
something that we i think as a society
are
all wrapping our heads around is human
beings are capable of of
the whole spectrum
and it's terrifying to think that there
can be good and evil in one you know and
that's
right well that's the nature of good and
evil i mean there's that's the great
duality right like in order to be and in
order to and it doesn't mean that
everybody has to do both right you know
what i mean of course not but it's and
most don't yes and that's why it is
terrifying when some do yeah um but yeah
i think we're at least now um
i don't want to say accepting but but
examining
the this this difficult part of the
human condition which is that you can be
capable of of
beautiful art yeah that speaks to many
and also be capable of terrible things
so yeah and how far back does it go well
how far back does this like pick up
we're not supposed to look at vancouver
yeah forever
yeah for sure some of the greatest art
that's why
whatever it's a longer conversation but
that's why i have a hard time just
saying like no more for this you know i
can't i can't stand that yeah no people
yeah people are like oh so-and-so's dead
so we can't they can't defend themselves
i'm like oh so we're not sp there are a
lot more dead people than a live people
yes that's true we're not supposed to
talk about people right yeah yeah okay i
did i just didn't know that absolutely
yeah i didn't know that like oh you okay
so we're not supposed to talk about like
what hitler did because you did speaking
of hitler
uh if you could have dinner with three
people
uh who's your favorite muppet huh i
um
all i can think of is rolf oh no that's
great okay no that that's good that's
any meaning that's who's coming up i'm
surprised at myself that i'm not saying
this piggy bank no ralph's coming
through oh he was uh an entertainer he
was yeah
always had a little jimmy draney uh-huh
that's a lot yeah
he's very jimmy jr yeah
uh who what is your most commonly used
emoji um i
um
i i'm trying to like do math yeah when
you're texting like what's like usually
first i do this one a lot oh and she's
doing like a hang tag the hang tag
and i also do the sunglasses oh okay
that's a night yeah uh uh it's kind of
it's like says nothing generic plenty
yes yes
it says exactly what i wish the person
to interpret me as
cool cool both do that yeah hey man i'm
cool wow i just realized stuff about
myself that's interesting
these will be quicker camping or
glamping clamping
vanilla or chocolate
oh
i like vanilla malts better than
chocolate malts but i eat chocolate like
it's a vitamin okay
but in what form is your favorite if you
could dark chocolate yeah bricks like i
like i lit i got into that habit when i
was pregnant um because i read somewhere
that if you had dark chocolate as a
while you're pregnant you would have
calmer children oh really
did it work
no but i but i also i mean who knows
because maybe they're more than they
would have been yeah but um
but it just was a nice practice to like
have a little bit of chocolate every day
sure anything any excuse that you need
um
uh sweet savory what do you what do you
go what's your go-to um
that's that depends on where i'm at in
my cycle my friend okay all right i'm
not gonna touch that one uh
beetle stones
beetles um uh and and what would you
this is also another thoughtful one what
would you want your epitaph to read
oh
she loved
i i'm sure other people came up with
that one but that's she loved this great
no i have not heard that okay that's
yeah
that's really profound really nice i'm
gonna start crying
well i think about i often think about
because this show is called life is
short and i often think about it so i
said it with a question mark but i don't
mean it to be interesting no i don't
mean it to be with a question i know i
know she loved
dot dot dot
yeah
yeah yeah
you decide
okay uh you know your grandkids are like
yeah i think she did
um well i the great segue for
life is short and like thanks for being
here thank you this is fun this is nice
uh okay i didn't even have to put up
makeup um i put on makeup just because i
like them
thanks for listening and thanks for
being here pal bye
so guess what what that happened whoa
wow back by popular demand the intro to
the outro intro to the outro i like that
so we could change it nope thank you
guys for for i hope you enjoyed that
also before we get into it um all of
your feedback has been
really helpful most of it's been really
helpful some of it has been
a little less helpful than less helpful
than others how about that okay well uh
what do you think i like how you
parrot her not just hers but everyone's
that's the first thing i notice that you
you parrot people's voice their accents
back
you just started repeating words that
she said in her chicago accent and and
she was like are you gonna do this the
whole time time and i do that we're like
no i'll try not to you know we also you
can't help yourself but i well it's also
i i know i was just gonna try to defend
it and i can't because that word
parroting is perfect for it but i've
always thought of parents as being like
like like probably want to cry you know
they're annoying parrots are they're
beautiful and all that and it's
impressive that birds can do that but
for a human they are annoying parrots
are annoying yeah i don't think parrots
get enough credit for being able to do
that that's an amazing thing they can do
do you imagine if any other animal could
do that my ex that had that beautiful
dog occasionally she would sing no no
she had this beautiful voice and the dog
would go
that's different that's just a sound but
words parrots can parrot words
if you say
gonna have some coffee they're gonna
have some coffee but they don't know
what they're saying so what
it's still impressive you're saying in
the animal kingdom i'm saying parrots
are extremely impressive yeah and it
would be very bizarre if any other
animal could do that that's a rare
combination to be impressive and
annoying
it is you know yeah who else is
impressive and annoying um
mark zuckerberg
oh yeah gilbert godfrey i don't even
find him annoying really then i kind of
like that yeah that's part of his bobcat
by the way he doesn't really talk like
that and i mean is this uh do people
just i assumed he did talk like should
we save this for the gilbert godfrey
episode it'd be cool to have him on
actually um another thing i noticed
don't take too much offense
to this but can't wait for this she is
smarter than you uh-huh i'm not offended
by them she she's just
so well read yeah and she's assured and
she's just i was playing catch-up she
was ahead of yeah and she was like oh
that's very eckhart toll she referenced
her talk and i could tell you didn't
fully get the reference
i know but you didn't really get what
she meant so you were like yeah
you sort of you like weakly agreed to it
with her it's really funny yeah that's
right i noticed that about the linum
lena dunham lena said a few things like
that right it was she she had some
reference that was over my head and i
was like yeah yeah anyway uh
have you ever noticed when you hang out
with
a person
for a long time you start to sound like
that oh my god haven't we talked about
this on the show you do it i think you
do it more immediately than most people
yeah i mean i remember i remember in
high school watching this movie um
was it gallipoli that was an australian
movie
starring a very young mel gibson pre-pch
anti-semitic rant mel gibson um
and save it for the mel gibson interview
and he was i remember at the end like
talking you know
having having a little accent i don't
know why i do that that's i wonder i
don't know i don't know if i should work
on it or if it's maybe good for me to do
that i love soaking those things up i
think it's who you i wouldn't run from
that but that's so much of what makes
you you i think the fact that you
absorb
other people when you talk to them i
think that makes you an effective
interviewer but it also makes you an
effective um
doesn't everyone do that yeah i do
i think so but you do it more it's like
[Laughter]
but i think it's fine you should be who
you are uh she references the finer
things in life and you reference the
bachelor
but that's just who you are so it's fine
to me that's one of the finer things in
life that that's a pleasurable thing in
life to watch that show what she said
about being a child actress was so
interesting uh because
her
mom sounds like she did a really good
job of keeping her yes as normal as
possible during that time yeah and
relatively speaking
uh for child stars i think she had a
pretty normal totally
but even with that there she talked
about the trappings of you know the way
your
certain extended family treated her and
it's weird
must be such a strange experience such a
mind [ __ ] yeah and she was talking about
how she was nervous to meet macaulay
culkin and
because
she was so good at and used to pleasing
adults yeah but
not kids because she was they appeared
they picked last year yeah
you know all that stuff all all the
things that every kid kind of has to
deal with but then on top of that she is
this kid who's in movies and known a
little bit so i'm sure there was weird
jealousy issues and but with adults she
you know she could walk into an audition
that makes sense he's fine yeah i can
see that i can see that and i wonder now
how much that's affected her i mean we
got into it a little bit about the
desire to please and and to um be liked
and to fit in you know i like when you
spoke portuguese with her oh yeah yeah
they just came out i was how did you
know i didn't have a new portrait no i
didn't either it just came out and she
seemed to be seemed to mean something to
me that was really impressive i mean
that's what really intelligent people do
sometimes they don't have a barometer
for
how unintelligent other people are you
know so they'll just like she's busted
out portuguese like our father does that
sometimes he'll just start speaking like
you know he'll say a latin phrase or
he'll reference a 16th century
philosopher or who
no one really like seven people in the
world know and he's like well it's like
when saint petruccio's
like what oh i forgot that most people
don't know that uh i like that you
couldn't let the roberta flack puns go
oh man
she's she's telling us
she's telling this life-altering story
that she experienced she got back into
acting and and i could i could hear you
just thinking of flak puns as she was
telling this story
even now i'm thinking you were you were
maintaining eye contact but you were
like uh-huh but i could see the wheels
turning the flak pun wheel you saw the
flaction in my eyes
you had real inflation my eyes were very
reflective
she wanted you to get back into flacking
it's so stupid
the final
nerdy moment that she that cemented if
there was ever any doubt speaking of
nerdy moments that was a nerdy moment i
just had ah it was nerdy yeah yeah
oh dang it the the moment that cemented
her nerdiness was
to for me was when you asked her if
what sport she would play
and she said
i've never been very good at athletics
the fact that she called it athletics
you know that you're not going to sport
when you call it athletics gamesmanship
[Laughter]
yeah i i am not athletically inclined
and i really enjoyed seeing her again
and getting to catch up and uh i hope
you guys enjoyed oh god you need to work
on your endings
it was a little shlumsky sorry about
that schlumzy ending justin's gonna be
working on uh wrapping up episodes yeah
um
all week but include that in the reviews
oh yeah include that in your five star
reviews
say i love the show five stars justin
peters out at times i don't need to hear
it but it might encourage me to work on
it
um so
that was it thank you for listening life
could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you for listening to life is short
if you like the show please give us a
five star review and tell your friends
to subscribe
and and if you've told them once keep
badgering them they'll like that we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcast and every major listening
app as well as wondering.com support the
show by answering a survey on
wandery.com
survey life is short is hosted by me
justin long is produced by christian
long and megan monaco senior producers
michelle lanz executive produced by
marsha louis and hernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
who's gonna be on
i don't think so
you're gonna like her
oh she's on veep
no you didn't do oh you mean chomsky
oh god i forget her name clump schlumsky
oh i'm polish i should know this
i i hate when people
massacre um as islamic names
anna
and anna anna schlomsky no that's not
right oh my goodness well don't freak
out you'll find out on tuesday how to
say it
oh isn't that awful and she's so cute
i should get her name
it's klumsky
you don't print there's not an h in
there nope klumsky like christian
like your song
oh no no like is it ch no yeah
yeah so
oh i see what you're saying klumsky yeah
klumsky yeah wow
okay i think i got it i don't think so
we'll see
probably not
you